Speaker 1: In the aftermath of both the Kyle
Rittenhouse trial and the trial over the
killing of Ahmad Arbery, now the Gillane Maxwell
trial has started and this is the trial over
Julian Maxwell colloquially believed to be sort
of like the fixer for much of the sexual assault
that the late Jeffrey Epstein was involved in.
Julian Maxwell, both his girlfriend and also
sort of, you know, a lot of this is allegations
that that are being explored but believed to
be accused of being someone who helped
groom and get women into this kind of
perverse alleged system of abuse that Epstein
perpetuated. And in the last few days, folks
including like Lauren Boebert, the Republican
congresswoman whose vile, I mean, just vile,
disgusting woman made a big deal of saying the
left is worried about this trial because a lot
of leftists are going to be exposed for maybe
being involved with Jeffrey Epstein. Well,
yesterday, Jeffrey Epstein's former airplane pilot
testified and named Donald Trump as a passenger
on Epstein's what was sometimes called shockingly,
the Lolita Express, also naming Bill Clinton.
The point here is not that this doesn't hit
Democrats and Republicans, but rather that it
basically just involves powerful men who want to
be around rich people, powerful people and young,
attractive women, quite frankly. And so this
is potentially not going to go well for a lot
of different people. A bunch of interesting
reports, including this one from Newsweek,
which says Trump Clinton among famous fliers. No
sex acts seen on Jeffrey Epstein's jet pilot says
Jeffrey Epstein's former pilot testified Tuesday
in the sex trafficking trial of Glenn Maxwell,
saying he never saw any evidence of sexual
activity when he was flying Epstein's plane. You
know, that could be meaningful or not. Oftentimes,
the pilots don't leave the cockpit during during
these flights, which are often just a few hours.
The Associated Press reported that Laurence Paul
Vysotsky Jr. was Epstein's pilot for nearly 30
years, piloted around a thousand flights between
'91 and 2019. He said he flew famous people such
as Prince Andrew, whose association with Epstein
was already known. Former U.S. presidents Bill
Clinton and Donald Trump. Maxwell has been accused
of recruiting and grooming girls that Epstein was
accused of sexually abusing for at least 10 years
starting in 2004. Vysotsky said in the hierarchy
of Epstein's world, Maxwell was the number two,
while Epstein was the big number one. Some
media members have called Epstein's plane
the Lolita Express. After allegations surfaced,
he used it to fly teen girls to his properties.
Though Vysotsky says he stayed in the
cockpit for the majority of the flights,
he said Epstein never warned him to stay there and
encouraged him to use the bathroom in the back,
which would require him to walk through the
length of the plane. When Maxwell's attorney,
Christian Avoidable, asked Vysotsky if he had ever
seen sexual activity or toys on the plane, he said
never. He also said he had absolutely not seen any
sexual activity with underage girls on the plane,
adding he had also never seen children on
the plane who were not with their parents.
Whenever Doyle asked about a teenager who
prosecutors say was sexually abused by Epstein
before she became an adult. Vysotsky said he
believed she was mature when he was introduced
to her. He also acknowledged that Bill Clinton
was a passenger on a few flights in the 2000s had
piloted planes with Britain's Prince Andrew, the
late U.S. Senator John Glenn and former presidents
Donald Trump and Bill Clinton more than once more
than once. So listen, this is being made out to be
Partizan. The right is saying this was
a Democratic sexual assault party plane,
Bill Clinton ET. Some on the left are saying it's
Trump who was really the guy here. It's everybody,
guys, and it's everybody who was on the planes.
Republicans and Democrats in terms of sexual
assault, we don't know now it should be said,
and I want to be really careful how I say it.
There have been allegations.
Made against Epstein and Trump
as a. What's the even word as a team? I
mean, I don't even know what to say about
what I believe would qualify as gang rape of a
minor. That's an allegation that has been made,
but charges have been dropped and there's a
lot of complication about it. But we've seen
the video of Donald Trump and Jeffrey Epstein at
a party sort of like evaluating and rating women
who were dancing based on the video. We don't have
any evidence that those women were underage. They
all appear to have been of age. But my instinct
is there's a lot of people wrapped up with this,
and I don't believe that it is a Partizan thing.
And we're going to see what comes out now. A lot
of people have gotten very conspiratorial saying
whoa on the first day of Glenn Maxwell's trial.
Jack Dorsey steps down as CEO of Twitter.
There's no evidence whatsoever that the two
things are related. Another one is the day
Omicron Macron is announced. There's Elaine
Maxwell trial starts. Actually, that's not even
true. The trial started Monday. Omicron sort of
became national global news on Friday. It does,
doesn't even really make sense. That being said,
without going any further. Of course, if
Julian Maxwell is found dead by suicide.
I will be wondering about that. That would
be very, very strange and OK, yeah, I mean,
you know, that's the email I get most frequently,
David, will you will you concede that if Dylan
Maxwell takes her own life, that it would be
strange? Yeah. I mean, it hasn't happened.
It's a hypothetical. It has not happened.
But yes, that would be a strange thing.
This is bipartisan trouble, quite frankly, and it
doesn't look like it's going to stop anytime soon